a
faire l'unanimité contre lui par
son attitude, par ses propos
hier la chambre de commerce de
Montréal.
J'en parle avec le commissaire
aux langues officielles, Raymond
Théberge.
- Vous avez reçu pour cet
événement de sa plainte.
- Tout à fait on a reçu jusqu'à
date de 100 plaintes.
- Ce qui est énorme, hors du
commun.
- Tout à fai à fai à fait. On rt
dépendamment de l'événement
quelques dizaines de plaintes.
Reçu un nombre de plaintes
extraordinaires par rapport a
d'autres événements, mais pour
un discours, comme
extraordinaires.
t un record absolu,
presque.
- Oui.
- Raco- Raco- Racontez-moi, avae
discours d'hier midi, vous aviez
vu de Montréal nous avait
appris, qu'il allait parler
juste en anglais. Est-ce exact
que vous avez pris comme
démarche d'appeler Canada, de
leur dire écouter, je ne vous
conseille pas de faire ça. Il
avait été prévenu par vousavant.
- Oui. Mon bureau une fois qu'on
a été au courant du fait que le
discours serait uniquement en
anglais, mon bureau a contacté
Air Canada pour leur faire
valoir nos préoccupations.
Évidemment, le discours a été
prononcé en anglais. Avec le
résultat qu'on voit
présentement.
- Répondre aux gens chez vous
qui ont appelé Canada. Quelques
nazis?
- Certainement qu'on a dit c'est
que c'est un discours la chambre
de commerce, un discours la
communauté des affaires. Ce
n'était pas vu communication
avec le public tel que défini
par la loi comme les langu
officielles. Évidemment,
plusieurs citoyens et
citoyennes, ce discours a été
perçu et vu communication avec
le public qui explique le nombre
important de plaintes qu'on a
reçues.
- Monsieur Théberge, Air Canada
est assujetti sur la loi sur les
langues officielles de ce pays.
Est-ce que le grand patron
devraibilingue sbilingue sbilinn
vous?
- A mon avis, étant donné le
symbolr de la Canada,
je pense que le haut dirigeant,
le premier dirigeant de
l'entreprise comme toutes les
institutions fédérales devraient
être bilingues. Être en mesure
muniquer lmuniquer lmuniquer lms
officielles non seulement aux
employés aux autres
intervenants, mais la population
enne partout.
- Ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu Belley-Rosa que
d'une telle réaction. Beaucoup
de gens soulignent que AirCanade
quant aux langues officielles.
Qu'est-ce que vous en dites?
- Année après année, on reçoit
un nombre de plaintes vis-
d'Air Canada. Vis-à-vis les
téléservices surtout en
français. Sur les avions, soit
dans les aéroports. Ça perdure
depuis plusieurs années. Mon
prédécesseur avait émis un
rapport spécial au gouvernement
le grondement n'a pas agi. On
nous a laissé entendre que lors
de la médiation de la loi, était
pour se pencher là-dessus. Pas
toujours un savoir quelles
seront les prochaines étapes
cette modernisation?
- est-ce que vous êtes
découragés face à l'attitude Air
Canada.
- Je suis souvent commissaire,
soit préoccupé et déçu. Je
recommence souvent, des
recommandations, un nombre
incroyable de recommandations.
C'est souvent a refaire. Les
rendue OK mon avis, c'est
systémique. On doit trouver une
approche beaucoup plus globale
pour essayer de traiter de cette
situation. Le commissaire n'a
pas les pouvoirs pour le faire
les pouvoirs de recommandations.
A ce moment-ci, on répète
souvent les mêmes gestes avec
les mêmes résultats.
- Est-ce que la nouvelle loi
qu'avait déposée Mme Joly être
redéposée, est-ce que va donner
plus de mordant au gouvernement
pour faire quelque chose?
- Dans le projet de loi qui est
mort, effectivement on accordait
au commissaire de nouveaux
pouvoirs en matière...? De
pouvoir qui n'existe pas
maintenant.
- Il y avait plus de moyens.
Merci de nous avoir parlé.
Commissaire aux langues
officielles qui en appelaient
les barra avec et de ses deux
mandats. Merci de nous en avoir
parlé en direct.
Peter Trent, ancien maire de
Westmount pendant cinq mandats.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Quelques avaient eu comme
réaction?
j'ai entendu d'autres
anglophones en disant et ne nous
rends pas service donnant une
image de la communauté
anglophone un peu arriérée.
- Moi je suis un peu sidéré par
cette nouvelle. Première
réaction est très simple. Est-ce
que nous sommes toujours en
1960?
je trouve que c'est vraiment
impensable que le PDG
d'un organisme semblable
a travers le Canada n'est pas
capable de s'exprimer en
français. Je trouve que ce n'est
pas acceptable. Je trouve en
tant qu'anglophone je suis un
peu gêné. Surtout en parle de
congés de loi, 96 où on veut, le
cul qui vu les assouplissements.
Maintenant on a cette affaire.
Je trouve que ce n'est pas
acceptable.
- Vous avez vu la des relents
des années 60. Vous avez vu la
des relents que les gens
d'affaires de Montréal parlaient
en anglais alors employés. Ne se
laissait pas apprendre le
français.
- C'est ça. Je suis arrivé ici
au Québec 69 c'était comme ça.
La plupart des dirigeants, les
conseils de municipalité ne
parlaient pas un mot français.
Moi, je ne parlais pas français
non plus. Mais au moins j'ai
pris le trouble de l'apprendre.
Je trouve que même si ma France
n'est pas impeccable, il faut
dire que Monsieur Rousseau dans
un français impeccable. Le
français pour communiquer et
respecter la majorité des gens
qui habitent ici au Québec.
- L'Elle Québec communiqué
groupe network qui représente la
communauté anglophone qui a dit:
je ne fais un tort incroyable.
Même les excuses arriveront pas
a faire disparaître le temps que
ça causait la communauté
anglophone. Ça donne une image
de nous dépasser. Donc, vous
êtes d'accord. A ce moment-ci
peut-il, selon vous rester en
poste?
- Il faut questionner le
jugement de son conseil
d'administration. Indianna : 12
personnes qui composent le
conseil. Mon avis, ce n'est pas
juste la faute de Monsieur
Rousseau, c'est la faute... il
ignorait la réalité du Québec et
aussi du Canada. Il ne faut pas
oublier c'est les gens des fois
l'extérieur du Québec. Il faut
garder en tête dans ce dossier.
- Vous avez évoqué et c'est
connu, la communauté anglophone
voudrait voir des changements au
projet de loi pour que change la
loi 101 de Monsieur Jolin-
Barrette. Est-ce que vous vous
êtes dits hier, ça y est, ne
pourra jamais plaider des
changements ça va juste être une
loi de travaux est plus dur qui
va arriver?
- Justement c'est ça ma crainte.
Parce qu'il y a des définitions
anglophones historique peut-être
que je suis un anglais AG, je ne
me considère pas anglophone
historique. Étant donné la
langue je parle ici. Qui peut
recevoir les services en
anglais. Il me semble que les
francophones sont assez généreux
peut-être faire les
assouplissements là-dedans. Mais
avec cette affaire qui arrive,
me semble que ça va être plus
difficile de convaincre Monsieur
Legault de faire les
assouplissements cette loi.
- Au projet de loi 96. Ancien
maire de West demande, merci de
nous avoir parlé en direct